heureux que vous deviez m'aider je ne peux tout simplement pas le
faire vous avez raison si vous
vous dites que vous ne pouvez pas le faire vous ne
pourrez pas le faire vous avez un titre mon héros
que saurais-je sur les héros hé à partir de
quand tu '  re dans la guerre seul un lâche
tourne le dos à son peuple c'est une
guerre dont vous avez besoin pour combattre le rassemblement de
tous ceux qu'ils vous ont à
ces gens comme vous repérez des gens mon
nom est Robin Hagen vous connaissez les
adolescents de Logica qui est en  charge ici
qui est en charge ici je suis monsieur je
cherche une femme
unité bartosh ils l'ont emmenée
quelque part oh wow comment pouvons-nous les vaincre
nous nous battons je sais que vous avez peur mais vous
devez avoir du courage aujourd'hui nous nous levons et
nous  combattez
ces jeux auxquels vous jouez alors que de vrais
héros
vous